you just keep bringing me up hey guys
i'm lauren zima now Bachelorette villain
Chad Johnson got sent home as I miss him
so much but creator Mike Fleiss is
getting me all excited by teasing a Chad
spinoff now fly says Chad would not be
the bachelor instead he'd get his own
show hashtag Chad to the bone guys guys
imagine the possibilities we could watch
Chad eat I don't know if he's here for
the free food or if he's here to find
love watch him work out shirtless of
course we could watch people fear for
their lives you think I'm scared I think
you should be Oh Chad ultimately I just
want a good life for Chad I want to see
him find love find friends and
admittedly I want to see more moments
like this life ain't all blueberries and
paper airplane Johnny yes really hoping
the show actually happens would you
watch let me know on Twitter in the
meantime you've gotta follow chat on
snapchat it is so worth it hmm still so
pertinent and of course remember we'll
get to see him on bachelor in paradise
you know you like me